die blumen branche ist ein globales
milliardengeschäft
großbritannien ist der viertgrößte
blumen importeur doch woher kommen die
blumen
etwa 90 prozent kommen aus dem ausland
da schlägt das herz einfach höher
bei rosen aus kenia er nicht
die niederlande allein bedienen beinahe
die hälfte des globalen marktes
ihre gewaltigen hochtechnisierten blumen
fabriken erzeugen rund um die uhr 365
tage im jahr fast 200.000 blumen pro
stunde
die kluft es gewaltig wir haben 500
züchter in holland gibt es 10.000 klar
hängen die uns ab
niederlande preschen seit jahrzehnten
voran und unterstützen ihre blumen
branche großbritannien konnte nicht
schritt halten die britische und die
niederländische blumen branche sind wie
david und goliath aber die lage ist
nicht aussichtslos
wir blicken hinter die kulissen der
branche in den niederlanden wie auch bei
uns um herauszufinden wie britische
blumen wieder attraktiver werden können
der trend zu lokalen produkten ist eine
chance für britische züchter wir machen
kein thema das ist der unterschied in
holland geben sie damit an wir
konzentrieren uns ausmachen wir
erläutern die weltweite führungsposition
britischer event juristen
ich mag britische blumen hoffentlich
gibt es irgendwann mehr züchter und
auswahl
werden überleben
wir zeigen wie supermärkte uns beim
blumenkauf beeinflusst haben
bei uns gibt es quasi rumpsteak und
viele
schmorbraten gibt es im supermarkt
billiges hug an der ecke kaufte im
blumenladen
floristen sind echte miesepeter warum
sollen wir weitermachen wenn supermärkte
uns den handel abgraben
supermärkte sind gut für unser geschäft
wo und wie wir unsere blumen kaufen sagt
mehr über unser land aus als man meinen
sollte
[Musik]
vier uhr morgens in kommend gar dem
größten und exklusivsten britischen
blumengroßmarkt die hochwertigsten
blumen der welt werden gleich
tonnenweise für das morgendliche
blumengeschäft vorbereitet
das hier sind pink via nun ein von das
stück
[Musik]
das ist eine unvergleichliche
institution 1 uhr britischer teil
londons auch wenn nicht alle davon
wissen
du wirst von mal zu mal schön
sie die rose heißt langen
schwarzkümmel oder jungfer im grünen
klingende münze dennis adwords verkauft
hier seit 50 jahren blumen
glockenblumen wir sagen auch nachts auf
station
in covent garden werden täglich blum in
den wert von knapp 300.000 euro
umgeschlagen obwohl der umsatz seit den
1950 er jahren zurückgegangen ist heute
entscheidet weniger der preis sondern
die qualität der schnittblumen
[Musik]
so was sieht man nirgendwo sonst
das in knapp 500 pfund
eine kiste maiglöckchen
eine der beliebtesten blumen der welt
die marken verkauft hier in dritter
generation seit 36 jahren
so kommen sie in die vase damit sie weit
über den rand hängen
restaurants hotels
russische millionäre und militärisch
mitten ihre häuser damit
das funktioniert sie mittlerweile kaufen
drei viertel der floristen in diesem
teil des landes hier ihre blumen
die erfolgreichsten floristen kommen
hierher weil sie nur das beste wollen
also verkaufen wir es ihnen und sie
machen etwas besonderes daraus wirklich
erstaunliche dinge
die habe ich einfach mehr auswahl ja es
ist doch etwas teurer aber qualität hat
eben ihren preis
viele händler im covent garden wuchsen
mit britischen blumen auf
vor 50 jahren kamen fast alle blume in
dem vereinigten königreich verkauft
wurden aus britischer zucht importe aus
europa haben unsere blumen branche
jedoch zerstört und heutzutage kommen
fast 90 prozent unserer blumen aus dem
ausland allen voran aus den niederlanden
[Musik]
in holland wurde die branche stark
subventioniert und unterstützt werden
sie bei uns in vergessenheit geriet und
die subventionen nur in die
landwirtschaft lassen nicht in die
blumenzucht
[Musik]
die niederlande sind der größte und
fortschrittlichste schnittblumen
produzent der welt sie erzeugen den
großteil der blumen in unseren häusern
anders als in großbritannien entstehen
die meisten blüten hier ineffizienten
gewächshäuser die zum teil mehr energie
erzeugen als verbrauchen sie verringern
den co2 ausstoß und decken zehn prozent
des holländischen energiebedarfs der
computergestützten automatisierten
fertigungsstraßen sind weltweit einmalig
[Musik]
tausende holländische züchter sind teil
einer kooperative die internationale
blumen optionen abhält und täglich 45
millionen pflanzen verkauft ihre
vertriebs lagerhäuser sind die größten
überdachten gebäude der welt
die niederländische pflanzen branche
macht jährlich fast zehn milliarden euro
umsatz
beinahe ein viertel des weltweiten
gartenbaus
die kluft es gewaltig in holland gibt es
10.000 züchter tausende hektar an
gewächshäusern wir haben nur etwa 500
züchter natürlich hängen die uns ab
in holland wurden neue technologien
intelligent verwendet um ertrag und
qualität der blumen zu steigern
weshalb wir jetzt jahre hinterherhinken
und weder soviel noch so günstig
produzieren können
die niederlande sind uns so weit voraus
dass wir auch bei der englischen
national blume kaum mithalten können der
who sind die rosen werden immer besser
das
wird
mario land ist mit über 60 millionen
pflanzen der größte rosen produzent
europas
die brüder daniel und johann nutzen
neueste technologie um die perfekte rose
in großen mengen zu produzieren
viel schöner sehr weiß
lebendig
viele rosen wachsen hier nicht in erde
sondern schauen nährstoffe bekommen sie
über das wasser computer sorgen für
perfekte bedingungen
über rohre wird das unverzichtbare
kohlendioxid eingespeist ein
abfallprodukt der energieerzeugung
rosen züchten ist einfach man pflanzt
sie eingibt ihnen wasser die erde
erledigt den rest
wenn man aber geld mit einem guten
produkt verdienen will muss man besser
sein als alle anderen
[Musik]
die holländischen fabriken erzeugen
rosen höchster güte
ihr verarbeitungsprozess erzeugt über
100.000 rosen an die
[Musik]
kameras erfassen die länge des stils der
rose
sie zeigen wie dick die stile sind wie
groß die blüten sind und wie weit sie
schon geöffnet sind die
stärken unserer rosen aus holland liegen
in den großen blüten die bereits
geöffnet sind
sowie der ganzjährig stabilen qualität
die erreichen wir indem wir das klima im
gewächshaus kontrollieren darum stimmt
die qualität auch im winter
durch übernatürlich gute bedingungen
erreichen die rosen in holland ihren
höhepunkt schneller und in großer zahl
sie sehen aus wie britische rosen
unterscheiden sich jedoch in einem punkt
durch die zucht verströmen die meisten
dieser blumen keinen duft
die niederländischen züchter haben alle
ihre technologie und ihr wissen in die
zucht der schönsten rosen überhaupt
gestellt
die sie rosen sehen es war wunderschön
aus haben jedoch kaum bis gar keinen
duft
seitdem wurde der duft viel wichtiger
was für sie ein problem darstellt
jetzt müssen sie künstlich dürfte für
rosen war man sonst wieder die duftenden
politischen rosen kaufen würde
doch das rosen imperium der niederlande
hat auch andere probleme durch importe
aus dem ausland verschwanden in den
letzten 15 jahren drei viertel der
holländischen rosenzüchter
[Musik]
in covent garden werden die hochwertigen
niederländischen rosen von günstigeren
rivalen aus afrika und südamerika
verdrängt 70 prozent der verkauften
rosen in großbritannien kommen aus kenia
die kommen aus den niederlanden
[Musik]
und diese aus äthiopien
ein großer unterschied
münchen konnten sind die aus den
niederlanden zu teuer da müssen wir
günstigere kaufen weil sie viele
brauchen
wenn es aber um gleich bleibend
hochwertige rosen geht kauft man aus
holland
[Musik]
zwar sind 90 prozent der blumen hier
importware doch zehn prozent sind immer
noch aus britischer produktion
die 21 jährige floristin chargers
hampshire ist auf der suche nach ihnen
kannte ich die dort auch haben sie
profitiert vom neu entfachten interesse
an britischen blumen die nachfrage ist
groß
diese hier noch bitte natürlich
[Musik]
ich mag britische blumen sie haben ihren
eigenen charme
wachsen oft auf feldern und sind der
witterung ausgesetzt
gerne
englische blumen duften oft auch stärker
die erste niederlanden sind zwar schön
manchmal sogar schon zu perfekt aber sie
durften einfach zu oft nicht
was ist einmal so wichtiger
wir bleiben inländisch
[Musik]
doch großbritannien hat noch einen
weiten weg vor sich holland dominiert
den blumenmarkt seit jahrhunderten
die britische und die niederländische
blumen branche sind wie david und
goliath aber die lage ist nicht
aussichtslos
von märz bis mai präsentieren 500 der
besten blumen sich der hollands in
kollgen hofnarr amsterdam über sieben
millionen blumen
die vorherrschaft in der branche begann
mit der bescheidenen nationalblume
hollands der triple
[Musik]
sie haben ebenso einen weg gefunden
durch lizenzen für die zucht neuer arten
profit zu machen
wer arten aus holland anbaut zahlt
lizenzgebühren für jede blume insgesamt
knapp 3 milliarden euro jährlich
neue arten zu züchten ist auch in dieser
branche unerlässlich aber in
großbritannien gibt es keine programme
für neue schnitt luminaden mehr das ist
durchaus ein nachteil aber die zucht ist
sehr teuer damit sie sich lohnt braucht
man einen absatzmarkt und der ist in den
niederlanden offensichtlich vorhanden
[Musik]
schon seit dem 16 jahrhundert ist ganz
holland von der suche nach der perfekten
tulpe gesessen die niederlande
produzieren 9 milliarden tulpenzwiebel
im jahr
im land der tulpen suchte züchter ariel
schmidt nach einer ganz besonderen
schulte von der er sich in zukunft große
gewinne erhofft
großartig
eine mutation
manchmal ändern sich die erbinformation
in einer tulpe zufällig wodurch sie sich
völlig verändert sie ist wieder rot noch
gelb so hat man jedes jahr die chance
auf eine neue blumen hat
im moment ist es nur eine schöne tulpe
aber in ein paar jahren könnte eine neue
unterart entstehen die wir heute
zusammen entdeckt haben
die herausforderung bei einer neuen art
besteht darin ausreichend große mengen
für den handel zu produzieren doch aller
pracht zum trotz wird nicht eine dieser
vielen milliarden schulden blüten je im
verkauf land shop
[Musik]
erben frühling wird in holland
fünfeinhalb milliarden perfekten tools
der kopf abgeschnitten ist so erhält die
zwiebel mehr kraft und wird größer und
stärker
die zwiebeln werden jedes jahr
ausgegraben verteilt und wieder angebaut
es genug blumen für den kommerziellen
handel wachsen
die größten und besten zwiebeln werden
jeden herbst sprach ihnen verfrachtet um
zu überwintern
der narr ins kühlhaus bekommen tausende
zwiebeln wasser und nährstoffe gesicht
sagen
das ist die blüte dieser art sie steckt
völlig in der zwiebel
das ist ein besonderer raum mit etwa
800.000 holten
viele treffen
damit machen wir vielen eine freude
drei wochen nachdem die türken im
gewächshaus aufgewärmt wurden sind die
blumen reif für die ernte
eine neue art zu züchten und genügend
für den verkauf anzubauen dauert
unglaubliche 25 jahre
ab jetzt macht er 30.000 blumen pro
stunde
den ganzen tag sieben tage die woche
arians maschine trennt den ausschuss an
der zeit zwei sehr verschiedene
qualitätsstufen für zwei verschiedene
kunden kostet
die größten und teuersten tulpen mit
großen blüten und starten spielen kommen
in blauem papier zur floristin die
kleineren billigeren blumen hinweis
landen im supermarkt
eine charge von adrians besten tulpen
macht sich auf den weg ins auktionshaus
und wird in 48 stunden bei britischen
floristen sei die sind von mir
auf die alpen
[Musik]
fünf uhr morgens im auktionshaus in
narvik teil der blumen kooperative royal
floraholland hier wird der großteil
aller blumen weltweit verkauft 70
prozent davon aus holland
eine stunde vor auktionsbeginn sind
erste käufer auf schnäppchenjagd
rittersporn die bringen viel geld sicher
zwei bis zweieinhalb euro
mit dabei jeff clarke aus wechsel und
sie innenstadt floristen wie er haben es
nicht leicht in den letzten zehn jahren
mussten 40 prozent von ihnen schließen
um dies zu vermeiden begibt sich jeff
direkt in die höhle des löwen und kaufte
die blumen vom erzeuger er kommt als
einziger britischer florist seit 30
jahren hierher und sein geschäft
profitiert davon
nur wenig platz
er flieht jede woche blumen im wert von
knapp 3500 euro in seinen weg trotz
ausgaben von über 500 euro zahlt er
immer noch nur die hälfte im vergleich
zum britischen großhandel wenn alles gut
läuft bin ich vor ladenschluss wieder
zurück und die blumen land nicht mal
einen tag nachdem sie in holland
geschnitten wurden bei mir im wasser
frischer geht's nicht
wenn wir vor den elektrischen lagen
dagegen hält er an
ich bleibe sie gerne aus
als einziger brite ist chef hier seit
jahren bekannt wie ein bunter hund
ganz besonders
das ist mir neu
das erste auch zum ersten mal
das ist jetzt nur für die kamera
ich organisiere die blumen für etwa zehn
hochzeiten brauche daher also heute
besondere blumen
zb die hier
friedland rosen wunderschön und
umwerfend von einem der besten züchter
hollands
aber sie haben nur 9
13 mit längeren und 6 mit kürzer wer
zuerst kommt mahlt zuerst und ich
brauche zwei heimat also ein drittel der
kürzeren hosen hier
ich kann mir die smidt-arena schmidt 80
cent für 60 sicher
gestern waren es 85 us waren 85 so hoch
habe ich wohl verpasst dann mache ich 90
ich will nicht ohne sie zurück fahren
ist ein weiter weg
die blumen werden automatisch
transportiert und für das ausgeklügelte
system zur schau getragen käufer aus
aller welt gegen online auf bis zu 36
optionen 6 durch täglich fast 900
millionen euro umsatz entstehen
in holland werden jährlich 16 milliarden
blumen und pflanzen versteigert und das
sind 120.000 geschäfte und 45 millionen
blumen am tag
die niederlande sind die großmacht auf
dem schnittblumen markt und ihr
auktionssystem war der schlüssel dazu
ein britischer züchter muss zunächst
selbst einen käufer finden in den
niederlanden geht man einfach zur
auktion sie können zwar den preis nicht
festlegen aber dafür haben sie einen
marktplatz um den sie alle welt beneidet
[Musik]
anders als in großbritannien beginnen
auktionen in holland mit hohen preis und
der rote punkt markiert den preis auf
der uhr der langsam fällt käufer bieten
mit einem knopfdruck
denn jeff den knopf zuerst drückt
bekommt er die blumen zahlt aber einen
höheren preis wartet er sinkt der preis
aber er könnte sie verpassen
ich bin zur sicherheit auf 24 nein
verpasst man muss wirklich auf zack sein
um alles zu bekommen
da sind die rosen ich muss aufpassen
denn ich brauche die suite aaron rosen
unbedingt
ich biete hoch und sie mir zu sichern
für 86 cent danach 92 90
der letzte für 82 mein preis war okay
aber egal ich hab sie und ich bin
glücklich darüber
die musste ich unbedingt haben denn in
england sind sie fürchterlich teuer
damit chefs blumen frisch bleiben werden
sie aufgeteilt und mit wagen umgehend
aus der halle gefahren
bei einem lagerhaus mit der größe von
300 fußballfeldern ist schnelligkeit ein
muss
unser versprechen an die kunden ist dass
sie ihre blumen innerhalb von 90 minuten
bekommen egal wo auch immer sie im
gebäude sind
unsere 30.000 wagen teilen sich auf und
kümmern sich in wenigen stunden um die
kunden
das ist ein erstaunliches system
ein computer satie den fahrer wie viele
eimer er bei welchen käufer wagen
abliefern
die fahrer sehen ihrerseits beim
entladen die einzelnen eimer
so entsteht ein wohlgeordnete waren tanz
bei dem schnelligkeit und
unfallvermeidung an vorderster stelle
stehen
[Musik]
es überrascht nicht dass die hälfte
aller blumen und pflanzen über holland
umgeschlagen wird
[Musik]
die auktion hat jeff neun stunden
gekostet für den rückweg durch den
eurotunnel am gleichen tag braucht er
noch mal sechs stunden
wunderschöne ich hätte mehr kaufen
sollen
[Musik]
anders als chef liegen die meisten
britischen floristen weniger wert auf
den direkten einkauf
neben flora holland gibt es die
heemskerk flower exporters laut mit
ihren lastwagen sind sie die fliegenden
holländer vermittler zwischen
auktionshaus und britischen floristen 75
von ihnen handeln täglich mit
großbritannien
jeder lastwagen enthält blumen für bis
zu 35.000 euro ein jahres geschäft von
über einer million über 70 prozent der
britischen floristen kaufen direkt bei
solchen großmarkt vermittlern ein und
schmälern so den umsatz von jungen
märkten wie covern garten
[Musik]
der fliegende holländer willem van rijn
beliefert jede woche die gleichen 30
juristen an der südküste englands
ich bin ein fliegender holländer wie
früher ich arbeite seit 29 jahren in
england mein halbes leben lang meine
kinder und ich sagen immer ich bin ein
halber engländer
poppig menschen treffe oder blumen
verkaufen es geschieht jeden tag etwas
unerwartetes
ich liebe das
sie beliefern über 4000 blumenladen in
großbritannien ihre blumen sind teurer
als beim direkten kauf aber es spart
zeit und mühe oh ja schön
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich nehm 20 von denen danke
ich liebe es im laster alles gründlich
anfassen und ansehen zu können
wir freuen uns immer darauf
fast 30 prozent unserer blumen kaufen
wir von juristen viele halten besonders
hochwertige ware nach wie vor für den
schlüssel zum erfolg
[Applaus]
wir verkauften rosen aus holland
hier sind doch einfach schön mit
kräftigen blüten und sie sind lange
haltbar
sie dürften zwar nicht aber sie sind
wunderschön da geht mir das herz auf
anders als bei rosen aus kenia
etwas weiter finden wir den jüngsten
platzhirsch auf dem blumenmarkt der die
gleiche kundschaft umwirbt supermärkte
sie handeln nicht gern preise aus
sondern wollen genau wissen was wir
bekommen und supermärkte bieten genau
darf
wir wissen was der blumenstrauß kosten
wird beim floristen ist der preis etwas
schwerer zu durchschauen oft nicht
einmal ausgewiesen was an verunsichern
kann
britische floristen müssen nun kämpfen
landesweit verbuchen supermärkte fast 60
prozent der blumen käufe für sich und
wollen ihren marktanteil weiter ausbauen
wird die floristik in großbritannien
überleben
die niederlande sind das herz der 120
millionen euro schweren weltweiten
blumenindustrie
großbritannien kann nicht mithalten nur
zehn prozent der hier getauften blumen
sind britischer herkunft
[Musik]
trotz finanzieller nöte in den
vergangenen fünf jahren erlebte der
blumenmarkt einen aufschwung
vor 20 jahren verkauften supermärkte nur
ein fünftel aller schnittblumen heute
sind es fast zwei drittel
was sagst du zu den cup rosen verkaufen
die sich so oder fehlt da noch was
supermärkte sahen eine veränderung des
kundenverhaltens und reagieren schnell
gehen gut weg
sie werden immer wichtiger jetzt sind
sie schon neben zeitungen und magazinen
man kauft also zu seiner zeitschrift ein
paar blumen dazu bequemer geht es nicht
es ist schon ironisch dass wir ohne mit
der wimper zu zucken einen schokoriegel
für 150 kaufen obwohl wir dafür auch ein
paar bartnelken und wunderschöne
britische schwert blumen oder spray
macon für zwei pfund bekommen könnten
dinge die eine woche halten und nicht
nur ein paar stunden
die supermärkte verkaufen ganz bewusst
günstigere britische blumen und greifen
so unsere blumen züchtern finanziell
unter die arme
hier haben wir eine auswahl saisonaler
britischer blumen mit williams von
züchtern die weniger als 150 kilometer
entfernt sind lächeln garantiert
[Musik]
uns wurde beigebracht dass british
besser heißt warum sehen wir überall im
supermarkt unsere fahne auf dem
blumensträußen
in der vergangenheit waren blumen in
großbritannien ein luxus artikel wogegen
sie auf dem kontinent als
alltäglichkeiten
die supermärkte haben uns beigebracht
ebenso zu denken und sie zum teil
unseres wochen einkaufs zu machen was
wir früher sicher nicht getan hätten
die dominanz der supermärkte auf dem
markt spaltet die britische floristik
wir können es weder mit supermärkten
noch mit straßenhändlern aufnehmen
sondern müssen einfach anders sein und
uns mit besserem service absetzen
bei uns gibt es quasi rumpsteak und
viele
sportarten gibt es im supermarkt philips
hat an der ecke
gekauft im blumenladen
sie haben schöne blumen aber es ist
schon eine andere qualität solche hosen
findet man im supermarkt nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jeff ist nach zwei tagen auf der blumen
auktion zurück in wechsel
ich hab paradiesvögel bekommen
floristen sind echte miesepeter warum
sollen wir weitermachen wenn supermärkte
aus dem handel abgraben
wir sind nie schuld das waren immer die
andere
supermärkte sind gut für unser geschäft
sie platzieren blumen am ladeneingang
das erste was man dort sieht sind lunge
so erzielen sie die menschen jede woche
blumen zu kaufen wir müssen nur warten
bis die supermarkt blumen käufer sich
denken sie könnten ja mal bei einem
lokalen floristen vorbeischauen
supermärkte helfen auch unseren züchtern
den konkurrenzdruck durch importe zu
überstehen die britische
blumenproduktion wuchs dieses jahr um
10%
nord flowers in unserer blumen hochburg
lincolnshire kann technologisch zwar
nicht mit holland mithalten produziert
aber dennoch 120 millionen britische
blumen im jahr
sie kommen im september und sind bis
dezember weg jede hat ihre eigene woche
eigentümer markus hat besuch von blumen
käuferin louis sie beliefert drei der
größten britischen supermärkte
die britische blumenproduktion galt
lange als heim industrie doch das ändert
sich gerade
dank der supermärkte wuchs die britische
blumenproduktion um über 50 prozent in
zehn jahren
sie verkaufen sich dieses jahr gut aber
wir können die kunden besser ansprechen
das stimmt schon aber wir wollen dass
sie nicht im laden am schönsten sind
sondern wenn sie im haus der kunden
stehen
sie sollen ein tolles erlebnis bieten
damit die kunden sich beim nächsten mal
denken die waren super die nehme ich
noch mal
die britische pracht frisch zu halten
fällt nicht schwer dieses
vertriebszentrum ist nicht einmal 25
kilometer entfernt
überraschenderweise sind viele blumen
von britischen feldern besser als die
aus holland
es einige unserer arten verreisen nicht
gern holland kann hierbei nicht
mithalten
es gibt qualitativ nichts besseres für
kunden als britische blumen
in holland wachsen sie in kürzerer zeit
sie wachsen heißer und höher aber auch
leichter es ist ein anderes produkt und
sieht anders aus als unsere ware die
britischen stile sind gesünder mit mehr
blüte die ware aus holland wirkt er
gestreckt vielleicht würde uns etwas
holländische kühnheit auch nicht schaden
ganz sicher wir betonen unsere leistung
und qualität zu wenig
wir machen kein theater das ist der
unterschied in
holland geben sie damit an wir
konzentrieren uns aufs machen
mit britischer ware umgehen so vermerkte
den mittelsmann das hilft sich dann wie
marc finanziell dabei zu investieren ist
wir sind stolz darauf wir haben etwas
erschaffen gezüchtet und verpackt das
jetzt auf dem weg in jemandes hauses mit
den blumen aus diesen kleinen dorf wird
sich ein teil von uns im ganzen land
ausbreiten
[Musik]
die britische blumen branche ist
keineswegs verloren sondern hat eine
großartige zukunft vor sich die jedoch
in der hand weniger großer züchter
liegen sie wird immer nur einen teil der
britischen blumen käufe ausmachen aber
vielleicht kommen wir von zehn auf 25
das wäre ein gutes ziel für die nächsten
zehn zwanzig jahren
[Musik]
auch eine andere britische
erfolgsgeschichte könnte unsere blumen
branche reden nicht die größten
britischen talente ihnen den weg in die
zukunft und nehmen es mit der ganzen
welt auf
fantastisch das macht uns froh auch noch
in der national gallery was für eine
premiere
[Musik]
die zukunft der britischen blumen
branche sieht endlich wieder besser aus
in den letzten zehn jahren wuchs die
jungen produktion um 50 prozent im
covent garden ist man optimistisch die
umsätze steigen allen voran wegen der
event floristik hai in die seiner
aufträge für besondere anlässe und
feierlichkeiten
[Musik]
wie sehr es noch mit margeriten nicht in
den straßen sondern als tischdekoration
die event floristin charger für einige
künftige bräute durchkommen tagen und
sucht mit ihnen die blumen für die
brautsträuße aus
verwendet dabei nur blumen aus britische
man baut die nur zehn prozent des
verkaufsvolumens ausmacht
sie müssen ihr können noch auf die
tische wie geht's gut ich hab mich wohl
schön anziehen sollen
jk/c't john hat kassel ist einer von
sechs haupt zulieferern und arbeitet
seit 45 jahren in covent garden
um die jahreszeit haben wir die volle
auswahl
erst seit ein paar jahren dabei aber sie
macht sich fantastisch
sie taucht er plötzlich auf und kam
schnell groß raus
diese aufträge gab es vor zehn jahren
noch nicht das ist noch etwas neues
ich hoffe dass es uns erhalten bleibt
es leidenschaft für britische produkte
könnte schule machen und der heimischen
blumen branche helfen
unser know how in der event floristik
ist mittlerweile international gefragt
und fördert so das geschäft klingt lässt
ist
das ganze geschieht hier im süden
londons in diesem raum befinden sich 30
der besten britischen event floristen
jedes modul bekommt 11 giesskannen
wasser der weltbekannte florist robert
hornsby erhebt die kunst des blumen
designs auf ein völlig neues niveau mit
der wohl größten
ehrgeizigsten ausstellung aller zeiten
wenn das wasser in die oase eindringt
zieht es richtig durch
er muss in zwei tagen ein berühmtes
gemälde an der außenwand der national
gallery am trafalgar square in london
nachtruhe
wir müssen die blume sortieren damit wir
genug von jeder sorte für alle teile
haben
und dann in sechs bis acht stunden jedes
detail des ganzen bildes mit blumen
nachbarn
spätestens morgen 6 uhr sollte es dann
aussehen wie ein gemälde
eine gewaltige aufgabe eine lebende
skulptur neun meter hoch aus 30.000
frisch geschnittenem
blumenuhr tulpen für die toll
dass wir ordentlich aufmerksamkeit
erregen sowas habe ich noch nicht
gemacht ich bin immer fürchterlich
nervös dabei und halte es kaum aus
das ist ein ernstes geschäft es geht um
viel geld
ironischerweise kopiert einen maler aus
den niederlanden mit blumen aus holland
der sponsor dahinter ist das flower
council of holland das blumen aus aller
welt fördert
[Musik]
halb sechs uhr morgens im bett hemmten
in helsa
ich brauche noch etwas struktur das
funktioniert am besten mit natürlichen
sachen aus der umgebung
jay vollführt letzte handgriffe für die
hochzeit ihrer kunden
ich bin immer nervös bist die braut
ihren strauß bekommt sobald sie
glücklich ist dass alles okay aber
vorher liegen die nerven blank
diesem moment in dem sie hoffentlich in
tränen ausbricht weil sie ihr so
gefallen das ist einfach ein einmaliges
gefühl
man lässt jemandes traum wirklichkeit
wird klingt kitschig aber es ist einfach
etwas ganz besonderes
das ganze grünes british ebenso der
rittersporn
etwa drei viertel von allem ist
britischer
hochzeiten zwischen mai und september
kommen mindestens drei viertel unserer
blumen aus großbritannien wenn ich ja
alles
schön zu wissen wo die blumen herkommen
sie sind frischer und standen nicht drei
tage sinnlos herum außerdem unterstützen
sie britische geschäfte
[Musik]
ich liebe es von weiter weg sieht es aus
wie eine blume
drops meisterwerk erwacht endlich zum
leben
es ist eine tolle zeit für floristen die
branche wächst immer mehr über sich
hinaus
niemand bündeln so viele emotionen
sie berühren mit ihren farben formen und
düften unser innerstes
nicht nur sind sie von natur aus
großartig sondern bewirken durch unser
handwerk so viel mehr
es gibt wohl niemanden der bei so einem
anblick gar nichts spüren würde
[Musik]
britische blumen branche blickt einer
großartigen zukunft entgegen juristen in
der innenstadt werden wohl kaum
überleben wenn sie ihre strategien nicht
anpassen
im high end bereich mit luxuriösen
sträußen zu hotels und der ganzen event
floristik sehen wir jedoch einen sehr
aufregende markt der zum aushängeschild
der ganzen britischen wirtschaft werden
kann
ich liebe britische blumen und hoffe
dass es wieder mehr züchter gibt und wir
wieder mehr vielfalt bekommen damit die
branche wieder so wachsen kann wie vor
40 50 jahren
viele entdecken sie neu für sich genau
wie sie nun wert darauf legen woher ihr
essen und ihre kleider kommen blumen
sind eine logische nächste schritt
blumen gehören zum leben einfach dazu
gerade bei feierlichkeiten
die blumen werden bleiben
[Musik]
robs blumen puzzle nimmt vor der
national gallery in seinem rahmen
gestalt an
wenn alles glatt läuft erhofft sich das
museum rekordbesucherzahlen für seine
ausstellung niederländischer kunstwerk
fantastisch das macht uns froh auch noch
an der national gallery was für eine
premiere
es gibt wohl niemanden der blumen nicht
zumindest ein wenig mag
wir wollen die menschen erinnern als
blumen für sie tun was sie ausdrücken
können
[Musik]
ich finde es großartig dass bild erwacht
zum leben
sie haben alle teilen der blumen dafür
verwendet
atemberaubend einfach atemberaubend
[Musik]
die britische blumen branche mag um ihr
überleben kämpfen doch auch in den
niederlanden ist nicht alles eitel
sonnenschein
dort werden subventionen gestrichen mit
hilfe der supermärkte und event
floristik erwacht in der britischen
pfund schafft ein bewusstsein für
traditionelle blumen aus britischer
herkunft die briten wehren sich gegen
die übermacht aus dem ausland
baltische blumen sind etwas besonderes
sie unterstützen unsere branche und wir
haben einige fantastische züchter hier
idealerweise sollte die breite masse
mehr auf britische herkunft achten
greifen wir unseren züchtern unter die
arme
den kampf zwischen britischen und
holländischen blumenzüchter werden die
briten in sachen authentizität immer
gewinnen wir wollen nur beste britische
war hier ist ein strauß
wunderschön
glücklich sehr sehr glücklich
[Musik]